[Music]
imagine if you never had to plug in your
ev ever again what if you could just
leave it outside and it would charge
itself providing it was daytime and
sunny which it often isn't here
well buckle up because solar cars are
coming and i'm not just talking about
the weird prototypes you may have seen
in student projects and science
experiments
over the next two years a handful of
startups all plan on releasing
commercial solar assisted vehicles that
use the sun to charge their batteries
and can still be plugged in when it's
cloudy or nighttime so if solar cars are
soon set to hit the roads why aren't
solar panels on the roof of all evs well
for once it's sunny in london so let's
go outside and find out
okay first things first i want to define
how these startups are using solar so
under here i have a
solar car and
it's not going to win me many design
awards but it does have a solar panel
and a motor and when sun hits this solar
panel it generates electricity which
powers the motor but if the sun sets
the motor stops now the key difference
between my little toy solar car and
startup vehicles is this because the
startups are using solar in conjunction
with traditional plug-in ev charging
what that means is if you leave your car
outside and it's sunny the solar panels
will charge the battery of the car but
if it's cloudy or nighttime you can
still plug it in how much charge you get
from those solar panels varies wildly on
things like whether it's shady or not or
even what angle the sun is hitting those
solar panels basically it's as
changeable as the weather itself
however the performance of photovoltaics
and solar modules has has improved
dramatically in the last few years
that's bonner newman she's a senior
researcher in photovoltaics or solar
panels to you and me so in the last
decade we've seen approximately about a
40 increase in the performance and the
cost of those same solar components has
basically been reduced by almost 70
percent
in that same time period so now we have
very high efficiency very low cost solar
components that are being produced uh
globally now there have been solar
panels on evs before but it's that
reduction in cost and gain in efficiency
that has led these startups to create
vehicles that need to be plugged in a
lot less frequently so what are the cars
and how far could i drive one if i left
it charging in an average day of
sunlight
first up is the 32 000 sono scion leave
it outside for the day and the solar
panels on the roof and sides will give
you on average just under 10 miles of
range charge it fully and you can get
around 190 miles from the battery it's
affordable it's meant for the mass
market it's meant for families next is
light years like year one the five
square meters of solar panels on the
roof of this car will give you around 44
miles of range after an average day of
sunbathing with a maximum battery range
of over 450 miles but all that range
comes at a cost around 175 000 the
fascinating thing about solo cars is
that the best proportions uh are that
the car is long
wide and low because low and long for
aerodynamics and wide for the solar
panel and that actually makes for luxury
car aesthetics so that's great
and then there's this aptera's vehicle
also called the uptera
26 000 gives you three wheels and two
seats but also gives you up to 40 miles
of range from a day in the sun and the
company says you can upgrade the battery
to give up terra a whopping 1 000 miles
of range we have over 16 000 orders for
these now so
we're looking to start production on
these by the end of 2022 uh but
obviously you know you gotta
start with a trickle and then a flood
now i can't stress this enough this
isn't the distant future we're talking
about here lightyear and uptera have
both said that they'll be delivering
vehicles to customers this year so if
these startups can use solar to help
drivers plug in less why are we not
seeing solar panels on the roof of every
ev
well part of the reason is even though
solar is more efficient and affordable
than it was a decade ago some of that
efficiency is still lost when you
install it into a vehicle as we put them
into a module and put them between
layers of glass for example and put on
other protective elements then that
efficiency actually reduces and then on
top of that you also have the fact that
as it is driving through the world
the angle of the the module to the sun
is also changing on a on a fairly rapid
basis in order to make the solar panels
worth adding those startups have had to
completely redesign their vehicles to be
as light aerodynamic and efficient as
possible by moving the motors or
changing the body shape or putting solar
panels on as many surfaces as possible
and if you took the same solar packages
on the aptera and put it on say a prius
uh you may get maybe six or eight miles
a day of solar range from that prius if
traditional automakers were to try and
install solar on their vehicles it's
likely they'd have to go down the same
costly redesign process to see the
benefit from the solar and that might
not be worth it given that solar only
works some of the time and you still
have to plug in the rest of the time but
despite that we're still seeing solar
making some inroads on other vehicles
fisker has said that they intend to put
a solar panel on the roof of their
forthcoming ocean vehicle and even musk
has hinted that tesla's cyber truck
might come with a solar roof option and
in their journey to try and develop
these hyper efficient solar cars these
startups are making some really
interesting discoveries and generating a
lot of unique intellectual property
which in time may make its way into
other vehicles so make no mistake solar
assisted cars are coming and when they
get here i'm gonna have to find
somewhere else to park
hey if you want to know more about solar
evs my colleague rebecca elliott did a
great write-up for the future of
everything series i've left the link
below and as always if you're interested
in the future of how we might be getting
from a to b then don't forget to
subscribe see you soon